SHOCKING NEW TAX PLAN FROM MIKE
BLOOMBERG AND WHAT COULD BE THE
LAST EVER JOE BIDEN COMEDY
SEGMENTS.
HERE IS WHERE I WANT TO START.
THE SENATE MAY HAVE VOTED DOWN
THOSE ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT
THIS WEEK BUT THAT IS NOT THE
END OF THE STORY.
FIRST UP, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
LET ME PRESENT NEW ARTICLES TO
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI.
HERE THEY ARE.
THE ARTICLES OF INCOMPETENCE.
ARTICLE ONE, EVERYTHING YOU DO
TO TRY TO HURT THE PRESIDENT YOU
HATE BLOWS UP IN YOUR FACE.
JUST AS THE SENATE SHUT DOWN
YOUR IMPEACHMENT BARS, PRESIDENT
TRUMP’S APPROVAL RATING HIT A
RECORD HIGH AND IT IS OBVIOUS
WHY.
WHILE YOU SPENT THE LAST THREE
YEARS WORKING TO REVERSE THE
WILL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
PRESIDENT SPENT THE LAST THREE
YEARS WORKING TO HELP THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE RESULTS ARE PILING UP.
CHINA TRADE DEAL, USMC EIGHT,
TAX CUT 2.0 AND ANOTHER STRONG
JOBS REPORT ON FRIDAY.
MORE AMERICANS WORKING EARNINGS
MINING RISING.
ARTICLE OF INCOMPETENCE NUMBER
TWO, IOWA CAUCUS FIASCO SHOWED A
CLASSIC BRITISH EXPRESSION AT
THIS POINT YOU PEOPLE COULDN’T
ORGANIZE THE BREWERY.
THE WALL STREET JOURNAL PUT IT
THIS WAY, THE PARTY THAT
PROMISES TECHNOCRATIC MANAGEMENT
OF AMERICAN HEALTHCARE, ENERGY
AND FINANCE PROVES LESS ABLE TO
TALLY VOTES EVEN THEN THE
ANCIENT ATHENIANS FOR ARTICLE
THREE, YOU CAN’T CONTROL YOUR
TEMPER.
FOR THREE YEARS WE PUT UP WITH
THEIR ENDLESS LECTURES ABOUT
CIVILITY AND A FULLY DEMOCRATIC
NORMS AND THEN AT THE STATE OF
THE UNION YOU PUT ON THIS
EMBARRASSING PETULANT STUNT.
ARTICLE FOUR, EVEN WHEN THEY ARE
TRYING TO DECEIVE THE VOTERS THE
DEMOCRATS ARE INCOMPETENT.
ELIZABETH WARREN NEVER STOPS
RAISING THE ALARM ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND RAGING ABOUT THE
BILLIONAIRES.
PUT THOSE THINGS TOGETHER AND
WHAT TO GET?
PRIVATE JETS, GAS GUZZLING
[INAUDIBLE] YOU NEVER CATCH THE
GREEN CHAMPION ON ONE OF THOSE
BUT WATCH THIS.
THERE SHE IS, ELIZABETH WARREN,
ON A PRIVATE JET AND SHE
SUDDENLY REALIZES SHE’S BEING
FILMED.
SHE LITERALLY TRIES TO HIDE
BEHIND IN AID.
THESE LEFTIES ARE SO INCOMPETENT
THEY CAN’T EVEN COVER UP THEIR
OWN HYPOCRISY.
TODAY ON BEHALF OF A NATION
CRYING WITH LAUGHTER OF THE
DEMOCRATS WITH GREAT SADNESS AND
OF COURSE CAREFULNESS I SIGN
THESE FOUR ARTICLES OF
INCOMPETENCE.
THERE THEY ARE.
NANCY, I COULD SEND YOU THIS PEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE.
HERE IS THE OTHER WAY THAT
WEDNESDAY’S IMPEACHMENT VOTE
SHOULD NOT BE AND OF THE STORY.
FOR YEARS THE ALLEGED ABUSE OF
POWER AND CORRUPTION BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
INVESTIGATED OVER AND OVER AGAIN
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE ALLEGED
CORRUPTION, NOT A SINGLE
INVESTIGATION WITH SENATORS
GRASPING AT STRAWS PUSHING FOR
HUNTER BIDEN’S OVERSEAS BUT
WHERE HAD THEY BEEN WHEN WE’VE
LAID OUT THE BIDEN CROPS OVER
NEARLY YEAR?
HUNTER HIDES BY A UKRAINE ENERGY
COMPANY WHILE HIS DAD WAS
DIRECTING TAXPAYER DOLLARS
TOWARD UKRAINE’S ENERGY SECTOR.
YOU CAN SEE HE IS GUILTY FROM
THE WAY JOE BIDEN REACTS WHEN
CHALLENGED ON IT.
>> DO YOU THINK IT WAS WRONG FOR
HIM TO TAKE THAT POSITION?
>> NO.
>> KNOWING THAT IT WAS BECAUSE
THE COMPANY WANTED ACCESS TO
YOU.
>> THAT’S NOT TRUE.
YOU ARE SAYING THINGS YOU DO NOT
KNOW WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
BUT NO ONE SAID THAT BUT WHO
SAID THAT?
>> DON’T YOU THINK THAT IT’S
JUST ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHERE
PEOPLE THINK THAT SEEMS SLEAZY,
WHY WOULD HE HAVE THAT JOB IF
NOT FOR HIS WHO HIS FATHER WAS?
>> HE’S A BRIGHT GUY.
>> I GUESS THE QUESTION I’M
ASKING WAS IT RIGHT?
>> APPEARANCE.
WELL, HE SAID HE REGRETTED
HAVING DONE IT.
HE SPEAKS FOR HIMSELF.
HE’S A GROWN MAN.
>> YES, EXACTLY.
IN THE WITNESS CHAIR.
HUNTER BIDEN, TELL US YOUR
EXPERTISE IN UKRAINE AND YOUR
EXPERTISE AND ENERGY IN 2014
WHEN YOU WERE HIRED BY BURISMA.
WHEN YOU WERE WONDERING AROUND A
CRACK DEN IN LOS ANGELES IN 2016
WHILE ON THE BURISMA BOARD WAS
THAT ON BEHALF OF THE COMPANY?
HOW ABOUT JOE?
COULD YOU SPEAK FOR YOURSELF?
HOW MUCH U.S. TAXPAYER MONEY
WENT TO BURISMA WHILE YOUR SON
WAS ON THE BOARD AND YOU SENT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO UKRAINE’S
ENERGY INDUSTRY.
YOU SAID YOU DIDN’T KNOW ABOUT
YOUR SON’S TIES TO BURISMA BUT
LAST YEAR HE SAID HE TOLD YOU SO
WHO IS LYING?
YOU OR YOUR SON?
WHILE WE TALK ABOUT YOUR UKRAINE
CORRUPTION HOW ABOUT YOUR CHINA
CORRUPTION?
DO YOU REMEMBER THIS?
♪
>> JOE CHINA, WHAT EXACTING DID
HUNTER DO IN BEIJING IN DECEMBER
THERE ON AIR FORCE TO?
WASN’T A COINCIDENCE THAT LESS
THAN TWO WEEKS LATER HIS COMEDY
SIGNED AN UNPRECEDENTED
BILLION-DOLLAR DEAL WITH THE
STATE OWNED BANK OF CHINA?
ANY CONNECTION TO THE FACT THAT
YOU WENT SOFT ON CHINA JUST AT
THAT MOMENT?
STILL TO THIS DATE YOU SAY THERE
WERE NO COMPETITION.
IT DOES NOT STOP WITH HUNTER,
JOE COULD CORRUPTION IS A WHOLE
FAMILY BUSINESS FOR THE BIDENS
AS PETER SCHWEITZER DOCUMENTS IN
HIS NEW BOOK, PROFILES AND
CORRUPTION.
YOUR SON-IN-LAW WAS THE CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER AT A TINY
COMPANY CALLED DARK OP HEALTH
THAT WENT ON TO RECEIVE
UNPRECEDENTED ACCESS AND SUPPORT
FOR NEAR OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
FOR YOUR BROTHER JAMES WAS NO
EXPERIENCE IN CONSTRUCTION WAS
HIRED AS AN EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CONSTRUCTION
COMPANY THE HILLSTONE GROUP.
THIS WAS LESS THAN THREE WEEKS
IN THE PRESIDENT VISITED THE
WHITE HOUSE IN THE FOLLOWING
MONTHS HILLSTONE WAS ERODED TENS
OF MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS.
YOUR BROTHER FRANK WITH NO
EXPERIENCE IN REAL ESTATE OR
[INAUDIBLE] GOT LUCRATIVE REAL
ESTATE DEALS IN COSTA RICA
MONTHS AFTER YOU HAPPEN TO VISIT
THE COUNTRY’S VICE PRESIDENT.
HERE’S ANOTHER WAS TO RECOVER
COINCIDENCE WITH FRANK BIDEN PUT
THE GOVERNMENT DID A DEAL WITH
FRANK ENERGY COMPANY AND HE HAD
NO EXPERIENCE AND ENERGY EITHER
BUT ON THE SOLAR PROJECT
RECEIVED A U.S. TAXPAYER BACK
$6.5 MILLION LOAN.
WAIT, THERE’S A FRANK BIDEN
CARIBBEAN COINCIDENCE TOO.
JUNE 2014 VICE PRESIDENT YOU
ANNOUNCED THE LAUNCH OF THE NEW
PROGRAM TO BOOST FINANCING IN
THE CARIBBEAN ENERGY PROJECTS.
LATER ON THE OBAMA AND
MEDITATION ANNOUNCED A 47 AND
HALF MILLION DOLLAR LOAN TO
BUILD A 20-MEGAWATT SOLAR
FACILITY IN JAMAICA.
GUESS WHO ENDED UP SIGNING A
DEAL TO BUILD A 20 MEGAWATTS
SOLAR FACILITY IN JAMAICA?
THE MAN HIMSELF, FRANK BIDEN.
LOOKS LIKE FRANK IS THE NEW
HUNTER.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU, JOE BIDEN,
AND THE WHOLE CORRUPT TRUMP
BIDEN FAMILY, FOR DECADES YOU
HAVE GIFTED TAXPAYERS BY
PRETENDING TO BE A REGULAR
BLUE-COLLAR FAMILY.
WHAT A JOKE.
HERE IS THE QUESTION TONIGHT.
WHAT THE HELL DO WE HAVE TO DO
TO GET THE BIDEN CORRUPTION
INVESTIGATED?
FOR THREE YEARS PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS HIS ADMINISTRATION BLOCKED
AND PROBED AND HOUNDED BUT
NOTHING ON THE OTHER SIDE AND
THAT IS NOT FAIR?
THAT IS NOT JUSTICE.
THAT IS NOT THE RULE OF LAW BUT
THE LAW OF THE SWAMP AND THE
KING OF THE SWAMP IS JOE BIDEN.